the Joe Rogan experience what's a very
weird progressive argument and in it as
it pertains to race is always a weird
one right because white privilege to me
although you could look at what they're
saying on paper like yes yeah I'm sure
there's more black people that are
harassed by the police I'm sure there is
more black people who are treated
suspiciously by shop owners and the
length but the problem isn't the people
who aren't treated poorly the problem is
the people who treat the people poorly
the problem is racism the problem is not
people that didn't ask to be born white
or whatever they are and they don't get
harassed that so this idea of white
privilege or male privilege or whatever
it is that's not the problem
you'reyou're just looking at someone
who's not a victim of this particular
problem that you're highlighting but
you're not looking at the perpetrators
of the problem you're making people
perpetrators by simply existing and
having less melanin in their skin or
having their ancestors come as racism by
another it's a sneaky way racist yeah
and then they say you can't be racist
you it's not racist because you're white
that is hilarious if you can't be racist
against white people that one I thought
is a variation of the whole still while
I hit you argument you know it's not
struggling what I'm hitting you well
it's just so silly you've just
completely changed what racism means but
what's hilarious is it mostly the people
who are yelling racist or not the
minorities when I look on my Twitter or
my social media or in my news it's white
on white violence virtue signal yeah
it's white on white violence yeah mostly
going on is it's elitist White's blue
state whites college-educated whites
beating up on high school educated why
it's blue collar it's a white collar
versus blue collar war that's going on
and the rest of us are just kind of
watching like oh that's kind of
interesting well it's also a side effect
of the ability to broadcast right like
everyone with a Twitter handle has the
ability to broadcast everyone with a
Facebook page has the ability to
pontificate and have these long rambling
these huge statements that people put
out when you read them it's like how
much time did you put in this and what
the [ __ ] do you put that much time of
your kids
oh yeah job your job with your life or
your future or planning for you you know
what how much do you work out a day I
mean you just these some I've read some
people's Facebook posts I'm like this is
a preposterous amount of effort that you
put into saying virtually nothing
let's see humans are being creative yeah
it's an AI do that well that's true it
is creative it's creative in a very odd
way right because it's creative and that
they're trying to elicit a response from
people and they're trying to raise their
there's social value or raise their
position the social totem pole it's
signaling and it's easy signaling
because the kind of thing that everybody
has to agree with you on because nobody
wants to be seen as a horrible person
yeah and it's very hard to make the
nuanced arguments against then this is
just kind of go along right well it's
also it's some of it is so cliche that
it seems like I know one guy who poses
as a woman on Twitter but he does it
just well yeah what is this the name
Tatiana
McGrath yeah yeah you got real wick yeah
oh is that the same guy I think so yeah
that's hilarious
I did not they killed his account that
hundred percent sure we're pretending to
be transracial that's right they didn't
yeah he basically says all the crazy
stuff yes people on the left say but he
says the craziest version yes and kind
of just shows how it's okay it's like I
saw a tweet from recently just said or
her that it's not okay to be white and
some people agree it's it's so close to
what they say it's so close that it's
like the most artful form of subtle
parody because if you if you replace in
half of these things if you replace the
word white with black or Asian
what's the lynch mob dissent yeah yeah
it's it's a strange time in that respect
that favor something that if you want to
see who rules over you see who you're
not allowed to criticize mmm excellent
yeah that is a that's so true right yeah
that's so true
[Applause]